y
[Música]
el presidente joe biden firmó la ley
bipartidista aprobada por el congreso
que aumenta el control a la venta de
armas de fuego el mandatario señaló que
la normativa que incluye más fondos para
salud mental y para reforzar la
seguridad en las escuelas podría salvar
muchas vidas
miles de estadounidenses han marchado en
varias ciudades del país a favor y en
contra de la sentencia del tribunal
supremo que declaró ilegal el aborto a
nivel federal la casa blanca aseguró que
el presidente baiden trabaja en
soluciones alternas tras el fallo
rusia se hizo con el control total de la
ciudad ucraniana de severodonezk así lo
informaron las autoridades locales tras
semanas de resistencia y luego de que
ayer el gobierno de lugansk l pudieran
los soldados que resistían en la planta
de azote que abandonaran sus posiciones
se trata de una conquista clave para
rusia en el donbass tenemos reporte
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torre sánchez damos inicio
en eeuu porque el presidente yo bailé en
firmó la histórica ley bipartidista
aprobada por el congreso que restringe
el acceso a las armas de fuego en el
país se trata de la primera legislación
en casi 30 años aprobada sobre la
materia y llegó tras cumplirse un mes
del tiroteo en la primaria de walt de
donde murieron 19 niños y 2 maestras la
normativa estipula una revisión de
antecedentes cuando los compradores sean
menores de 21 años y mayores de 18 y
exige un examen exhaustivo de los
registros juveniles incluidos los de
salud mental asimismo extiende a todo el
país las llamadas leyes de alerta de
peligro previamente conversamos con
cristóbal vázquez corresponsal de france
24 quien nos habló sobre lo que esto
significa para el país y qué otros
aspectos cambian
es una nueva bastante importante sobre
todo precisamente después de estos
tiroteos y es importante también porque
es una de las pocas que se aprueba de
forma bipartidista es decir los
republicanos y los demócratas se
pusieron de acuerdo uno de los aspectos
relevantes de esta ley es el punto en el
que se prohíbe a los abusadores
domésticos que fueron enjuiciados
adquirir un arma antes esta ley sólo
aplicaba para las personas que estaban
casadas y que estaban pues enjuiciadas
de violaciones en sus hogares de abuso
doméstico pero ahora pues esta ley se va
a expandir y va a aplicar también para
las parejas sentimentales que han sido
acusadas o están siendo investigadas ya
de uso doméstico para que no puedan
adquirir un arma sin embargo pues los
demócratas dicen que todavía hay vacíos
en esta ley porque no es retroactiva y
pues no aplica para las personas que
cometieron una violación doméstica
simple en estándares estadounidenses y
esto los demócratas pues lo ven
igualmente preocupación
y miles de estadounidenses han salido en
las calles del país para protestar tras
la anulación del fallo que protegía el
aborto a nivel federal las autoridades
de la ciudad y del estado de nueva york
de inmediato resaltaron que la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
seguirá siendo un derecho desde allí a
mensah la corresponsal de france 24 pudo
participar de la manifestación de hoy
si a quien no mayor y han comenzado las
protestas a favor y en contra del aborto
como podéis ver y es que estamos viendo
las dos posiciones una clara un claro
ejemplo de esa brecha profunda social
que divide a esta población a pesar de
que el 67 por ciento de los
estadounidenses está en contra de la
decisión del tribunal supremo- también
hay mucha gente que están a favor de esa
decisión estamos en un estado demócrata
nueva york es uno de los 16 estados de
este país que permitirá que se prepara
para recibir una avalancha de mujeres
que viven en los estados republicanos y
que buscarán estados como estos para
poder interrumpir su embarazo para que
se hagan una idea en este país hay 36
millones de mujeres en edad reproductiva
que viven en estados republicanos y que
no van a poder tener acceso al aborto
ahora otra cuestión que preocupa y mucho
uno de los jueces conservadores del
tribunal supremo- precisamente uno de
los jueces elegidos por el presidente en
donald trump ha sugerido que se revisen
las leyes las sentencias que permiten el
uso de anticonceptivos y el matrimonio
entre personas del mismo sexo algo que
preocupa mucho a la población y que
llega justo un día antes de que mañana
mismo comiencen las celebraciones en
gran parte del mundo por el orgullo
[Aplausos]
académicos y activistas han alertado de
los efectos que puede tener la
derogación sobre las mujeres y personas
gestantes afroestadounidenses
condiciones socioeconómicas como la
pobreza y la imposibilidad de acceder a
servicios de salud que ya ponían a esta
población en una posición más vulnerable
podrían ampliarse con su anulación en el
informe desde manuel a cano
un retroceso en los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos que toca especialmente a
las mujeres afroamericanas las alertas
se prenden sobre los efectos que tendrá
la derogación del road versus wave que
acabó con el derecho al aborto en eeuu
sobre las poblaciones más vulnerables
este momento es devastador porque lo que
significa es que en un lugar donde se
tiene la tasa más alta de mortalidad
materna en el país básicamente se está
condenando a las mujeres negras a la
muerte porque ya estamos muriendo en el
parto las cifras delatan las
complicaciones que podrían derivarse de
la anulación del fallo para las mujeres
afroamericanas antes de la decisión del
máximo tribunal este viernes las mujeres
afroamericanas tenían cerca de 3 veces
más probabilidades de morir por
complicaciones relacionadas al embarazo
y las mujeres en comunidades mayormente
afroamericanas tenían 63 por ciento más
de probabilidades que las mujeres
blancas de experimentar complicaciones
de salud durante el embarazo y el parto
además muchos de los estados en los que
ya se decidió anular el derecho al
aborto la mayoría de las personas que
buscaban estos procedimientos eran
afroamericanas por ejemplo en misisipí
representaban el 74 por ciento las
desigualdades socioeconómicas también
dejan a las mujeres afroamericanas en
una posición más vulnerable una de cada
cinco mujeres negras vive en la pobreza
una cifra que contrasta con las de las
mujeres blancas una de cada diez vive en
dicha condición esto no les permitiría
por ejemplo viajar a otros estados para
realizarse un procedimiento de aborto
estambul sexy work hip hop o hay un
movimiento para mantener pobres a las
personas pobres
entonces esta decisión realmente resta y
condena a una gran brecha
la anulación del histórico fallo podría
aumentar las desigualdades un estudio de
la universidad de duke del año pasado
mostraba que la prohibición total del
aborto podría aumentar las muertes
maternas afroamericanas en un 33% vamos
ahora hasta ucrania porque en la jornada
122 de guerra las tropas rusas se
hicieron con el control total de la
estratégica ciudad de severodonezk al
tiempo que aumentan los ataques contra
la vecina lysychansk ambas urbes eran
los últimos puntos fuertes de la
resistencia ucraniana en la región de
lugansk leticia álvarez corresponsal de
france 24 nos dio más detalles
pues está avanzando en el este de
ucrania en el donbass las tropas rusas
han entrado ya en la ciudad de lis y
chance y ahora mismo allí las batallas
están siendo calle a calle y cuerpo a
cuerpo según su propio gobernador
regional y si chance el último bastión
del ejército ucraniano en la región de
lugansk después de que severodonezk haya
sido tomada por las tropas rusas y
después de esa retirada del ejército
ucraniano tras cuatro meses de duros
enfrentamientos si finalmente las tropas
rusas toman en liza chance vladimir
putin estaría más cerca de lograr ese
objetivo que se había marcado para esta
segunda etapa de la invasión rusa en
ucrania que es controlar todo el donbass
la guerra continúa también en donges y
se teme que el siguiente objetivo sea la
ciudad de es la vía en donde se hay en
estos momentos mucha población que está
siendo evacuada de todas esas zonas y
viajen hasta ni pro pero también hasta
harkis donde nos encontramos aquí la
guerra se ha intensificado también el
número de ataques con misiles de medio y
largo alcance y también con artillería
ha aumentado en los últimos días y
aunque las fuentes oficiales nos dicen
que no peligro de que las tropas rusas
intenten avanzar y volver y volver a
ocupar territorios de esta región cuando
viajamos a esos pueblos las autoridades
locales verdaderamente tienen miedo de
que eso pueda ocurrir porque los ataques
han empeorado y han aumentado mucho en
las últimas horas
en este contexto el gobierno ruso
informó que suministrará a belarús
misiles tácticos iskander m como los que
haya empleado en medio de la invasión a
ucrania el anuncio fue hecho en medio de
la reunión que el presidente ruso
vladimir putin y su homólogo bielorruso
alexander lukachenko mantuvieron en san
petersburgo dichos proyectiles montados
en rampas autopropulsadas tienen un
alcance de hasta 500 kilómetros asimismo
el jefe del kremlin ofreció modernizar
los aviones de asaltos rusos con los que
cuentan las tropas de belarús
en otras noticias el alto representante
de la unión europea para asuntos
exteriores josep borrell afirmó en
teherán que las conversaciones para
salvar el pacto nuclear de 2015 se
reanudarán en los próximos días tras
meses de parálisis murray se reunió hoy
sábado con el ministro de exteriores
iraní hosein amir abdolahian para
abordar las negociaciones que intentan
salvar el acuerdo la unión europea
coordina las conversaciones en viena de
forma indirecta con los países firmantes
del acuerdo que limitaba el programa
atómico iraní a cambio del levantamiento
de sanciones para analizar esta
información conectamos con alejandro
corbacho él es experto en temas
militares y nucleares bienvenido a
france 24 murray habla de reactivación
de las conversaciones en los próximos
días pero ya irán dijo que todo depende
del levantamiento de sanciones entonces
qué se puede esperar de eeuu
es el problema que tenemos acá es que
los socios europeos de este acuerdo que
son el reino unido y alemania- y toda la
unión europea digamos
están a favor a están mostrando que
están a favor de iniciar el mejorar o
llegar a un acuerdo el acuerdo
básicamente el punto importante o
interesante es las sanciones sobre las
compras de exportaciones de petróleo de
irán la semana pasada el canciller de
rusia visitó a irán y dijo que porque
rusia también es parte de este acuerdo
que está a favor de mejorar este acuerdo
espero que los eeuu es quien se opone a
eeuu los motivos por los cuales se opone
es que es irán tiene comportamientos
poco voy a mostrado algunos
comportamientos poco transparentes y por
supuesto que uno de los elementos por
los cuales sancionados que apoyan a
grupos terroristas o acciones
desestabilizadoras en el resto del mundo
entonces ese hecho hace que bueno hay
que ver lo que va a ser eeuu de ahí
también acabe se ven en un complejo
entramado en el cual bueno
europea y los países de la unión europea
si quieren este tratado tienen que
convencer a los eeuu
claro y bueno del lado de irán es decir
no sólo enriquecido uranio superando el
nivel permitido sino que también ha
traspasado el límite de uranio
enriquecido y de hecho ha puesto también
en funcionamiento centrífugas que esto
lo prohibía el acuerdo realmente el
gobierno de brian rice y está dispuesto
a frenar esta práctica
bueno el problema es que este acuerdo o
sea irán abandono también cumplir o
intentar cumplir este este acuerdo a
partir de los ataques que se produjeron
que se produjo el año pasado en pero en
enero del 2020 en en bagdad donde se
asesinó a un alto líder militar iraní
digamos al cual eeuu lo señalaba como
como este actor que organizaba estas
estas tareas de desestabilización
internacional sobre todo en contra los
eeuu y occidente en general entonces
entonces éste
en ese sentido y gran abandono estoy
bueno y siguió como si con su camino
normal de no tratar de frenar su
producción de hecho ahora veremos si
verdaderamente la agencia atómica
internacional y que se encarga de
verificar esto había visto hasta hasta
que eeuu abandonaba el el acuerdo en el
2018 que éste irán estaba cumpliendo
entonces veremos la voluntad de los
actores si esto si realmente se pone en
funcionamiento y brevemente le preguntó
de verdad es posible revivir el acuerdo
de 2015 o hay posibilidad y
probabilidades de lograr un nuevo pacto
bueno se pueden el pacto que se lo que
se logró antes es muy muy bueno pero
bueno hoy como estamos viendo necesita
de que no haya vetos de actores muy
importantes
quizás el actor de eventos principal en
este momento de los eeuu y veremos cómo
evoluciona es cuánta paz quieren y yo te
diría cuánto petróleo necesita europa
occidental para todo esto no que ese es
un factor importante en esta en este
acuerdo con con irán en esta búsqueda de
acuerdo a lo que se trata en el fondo de
contener la proliferación nuclear y eso
eso positivo
señor corbacho a usted muchas gracias
por su análisis y por compartirlo con
nosotros en france 24 en múnich alemania
unas 1500 personas se congregaron para
protestar antes de la próxima cumbre del
g7 donde los jefes de estado de las
siete economías más avanzadas del mundo
se reunirán este domingo en baviera los
manifestantes con carteles y pancartas
criticaron la inacción del gobierno en
la protección del clima y pidieron
igualdad de acceso a las vacunas la
protesta significativamente más pequeña
de lo que se es comenzó en el lugar
conocido por albergar el oktoberfest
anual de mi única
y cientos de noruegos marcharon en oslo
para condenar el atentado en el que dos
personas perdieron la vida y otras 21
resultaron heridas en la madrugada del
sábado desafiando las restricciones
ordenadas por las autoridades y en una
muestra de solidaridad los manifestantes
aseguraron que el miedo no podrá callar
los ni acabar con la libertad en ese
país
así concluimos este informativo les
agradecemos su sintonía regresamos en
breve
[Música]